welcome to this video playing mr. Boris
now i'm actually not the rating favorite
here ok I've wrecked my my rating enough
so that i'm actually not the favorite
here ok this is one of those back in
lines where g6 is happening measure it
is right I take here and then g6 is the
move on I think I have to I have to make
sure that g6 is not hitting me pawn to
g6 playing this first I don't know H for
this is a move that I never studied
absolutely never
chan okay Black has the bishop pal this
is this is nice but the H file is a
cause for concern sometimes just going
to our maybe t6 yeah maybe just d 6 i'm
flexible i cannot i can ever I can play
d5 later I'd like to know where why this
going to castle here probably is going
for long castles right
hmm maybe if you castle its long now I
have some discoveries okay I don't
really understand why its plan here what
is it playing for really I mean I'm i
have this old covered is there any
tactical okay I'm simply not castling
here why I don't need you i mean i have
many other useful moves that I can play
a5 a4 using my long diagonal Bishop here
aha
so what does this mean and I go here
right 94 I can even play e5 I can play a
5 here also be five and d5 just grabbing
space v5 maybe night c4 comes but should
be sexist also a good move a bishop is 6
that's a simple move asking him what
about the a two-point and yeah I thought
Quincy five is good isn't it oh wait i
can actually no I cannot if i take it
you can take with the queen but i can
move the Queen that's no problem sb5
before is in the mix
now I'll be five Bishop takes a two Wow
maybe maybe he is going for for Queen h2
or something okay here i can actually
take on c3 oh I can take a tool that
takes on c3 is kind of shaky it's a bit
shaky at the end I'm in an awkward pin
this is not so nice okay let's just just
protect me five it's it's okay i think a
2 is also still hanging
yeah maybe I should have taken on c3 I
don't know Bishop c3b takes Queen takes
Queen takes a three was possible but at
the end I'm in an awkward pin so I
wasn't totally sure about the idea ok so
here what is he doing i can take a 2
here still but b5 hangs ok take if i go
be4 96 I'm not sure how good it is it
should be true yeah i can probably can
take
is also a five now
Becky position
yeah the c5 as an additional idea so
weird position yeah rook rook moves I
guess hmm 96 Queen takes c6 cannot
really be that convincing avoid let's to
move the rook
okay so whom I can also maybe just take
one deform but ok e5 is the principal
muha g5 where what is the Queen you're
doing just it just feels very loose like
I'm overlooking stuffing but okay Queen
age too so if i take here yeah that's
actually the main problem and i take
care RiRi captures my bishop is still
hanging but okay I have to play okay it
takes the screen g5 for Quincy one funny
route gauge 7 i'm probably just you sure
i i i i am i'm thinking of just castling
here actually can take their queen age
six bishop g6 sacrificing everything
okay ctx screen before check wins easily
see takes Queen takes g5 look here
Quincy want also wins so I think I'm
okay here I mean I think I'm winning
really should be winning the next two
piece and what is the big compensation I
have ruki eight shekels hi morning check
check check check and this check check
picking up the bishop now that's it
check okie dokie how do you do that I'm
covering basically everything and he has
no attack so activate this Quincy eight
yeah let's just trade queen seon
whatever i'm giving this away I
shouldn't have done that
yeah I'm allowing a bit too much
relaxing a little bit because of John
situation Jacqueline Kevin check me yeah
cannot defend with one second here but
yeah it was a caneva it was complicated
no idea I really think that this should
be really nice for black I mean I have
the bishop pair i have a good diagonal
on g7 I mean it must be good but it's
still it says it's notoriously murky
this kind of position Bishop here yeah
25 a compass on equal but not here okay
a 3 is even stronger than be five but
not much okay so computer likes my
choice and now it wants to take on c3
yeah i saw the move but I wasn't totally
sure about it I mean I saw that one I
was thinking that this kind of thing
here this is what I saw and I wasn't
sure about this because of the pin and
what am i doing I don't have the bishop
anymore this is in fact unclear computer
says equal but it wants to take here
here and now says I'm clearly better hmm
yeah it's not exactly simple it's your
play I came but this is not bad right
yeah it keeps a big advantage jigs and
now I an IT Phi F is also very strong
instead of e five even stronger nice
yeah that's it that's really nice bishop
moves and then black is attacking the
night is very strongly obviously okay
now then but ok five is not I'm okay
with the move what is it you should have
gone here we are protecting a protecting
g5 this is the point now this is in fact
not totally easy
here and he I'm winning writer yeah I
wanted to Castle first but he can he can
do that check and that's a draw
unfortunately yeah mattia I'm winning
with this idea yeah okay I think that
was an ok game it didn't do anything
anything terribly stupid him okay well
thanks for watching